bonjour philippe froguel et merci d'être
en direct avec une sur rt france en
angleterre le variant indien c'est plus
de la moitié des nouveaux cas en france
on en recense au moins 24 est ce qu'on
doit craindre une propagation comparable
à celle de londres
alors d'abord jaurès à lui ce que le fal
de l'ornement britannique j'étais à
l'android hier il ya une vraie
mobilisation il ya des quartiers de
londres qui sont à l'état de siège et
dans ces quartiers
conséquence massivement les porteurs de
virus puisque c'est la seule façon
aujourd'hui de le diagnostiquer et on
apporte beaucoup de vaccins dans la
danse dans ces quartiers alors en france
personne ne sait la situation real c'est
24 cas dans au moins deux cas sont des
cas dits endogène c'est à dire que ce
sont pas des gens qui venaient d'inde
ce n'est que la toute petite partie de
la au duo de liesberg qu'est ce qu'on
fait en france on l'a mis en place
jusqu'à présent aucun moyen de masse de
diagnostiquer le variant un indien et
quand on voit la carte de france et
d'europe surtout des décors n'a
l'impression qu'on né en 1986 à
tchernobyl
et toi et qu'on a été miraculeusement
protéger du danger
c'est simplement qu'on n'a pas mis en
place ce qu'il faut pour le poire on est
comme en français la différence du
moment britannique est complètement
aveugle et ne vois absolument pas ce qui
se passe donc d'après vous ce variant
les variants peut-être même en général
ne sont pas suffisamment surveillé pris
au sérieux par les autorités françaises
en français fait l'autruche et espère
que mettant la tête sous le sable
il va pas voir la réalité la réalité on
le sait il ya le nombre de cas qui ont
été annoncées officiel mais je répète ce
n'est qu'une toute petite partie de la
réalité puisqu'on fait on s'est ans très
peu a doublé en une semaine
les anglais le gouvernement britannique
prévoit que s'ils ne font rien ils vont
revenir à mille morts par jour - 2
juillet dix mille hospitalisation par
jour sont aujourd'hui elle dit morts par
jour
la france à 15 minutes a encore 17
milliards à 1 par jour de 200 morts on
va ouvrir la déconfinement le 19
si ce variant se dissémine très très
vite comme il le fait en angleterre
et bien alors on va directement à la
tragédie mais la tragédie qu'elle envoie
vraiment rien faire puisqu'on n'a pas
mis en place le moyen de retenir ce ce
variant ad c'est vraiment une situation
un rythme qui a appelé les visées hier
j'ai eu et j'ai eu l'impression de
réveiller la belle au bois dormant
est ce que c'est un variant qu'on peut
considérer comme plus contagieux que les
autres ce qu'on dit aujourd'hui c'est
qu'il est il serait 50% plus contagieux
que le variant anglais qui était
lui-même déjà 50% plus contagieux le
l'originel chinois ça veut dire en gros
que assists il se répand en france
son nombre de caves à peu près doublé
tous les cinq ou six jours et donc on
arrivera à la fin juin une situation qui
ressemble fortement à la situation qu'on
a eue nous on le barrio anglais il ya
deux mois
alors selon vous peut doit-il être fait
en france pour éviter cette propagation
du variant indien la première chose que
j'aimerais entendre le premier ministre
de la france j'aimerais entendre
monsieur macron faire comme boris
johnson
et dire qu'ils sont mobilisés et que ne
confondent pas calendrier électoral avec
le calendrier à sanitaires et chlorés le
plus important c'est pas les élections
assez de bloquer ces variants il n'y a
pas que celui-ci a on a découvert des
variances ans elle aurait muté du var
immigrés qu'ils qui inquiète beaucoup
santé publique france 2
pour faire très attention il faut
tripler le nombre de séquences qui sont
faites aujourd'hui en mobilisant le
secteur privé et les grands centres
génomique on est tous
ça fait un mois qu'on est en demande
l'autorisation mais c'est bloqué par les
lobbys les virologues et des centres
nationaux de référence qui a fait
pression sur le gouvernement en disant
mais non mais non on fait assez en arabe
on n'a pas besoin de mieux
mais ce qui était peut-être vrai hier ne
l'est plus aujourd'hui
et si on se mobilise pas comme le font
les anglais je trinque la tragédie soit
devant nous et quand on pourra pas aller
jusqu'au bout de notre plan des profits
de man est justement le déconfinement se
poursuit en france comme au royaume uni
est ce qu'on doit craindre le même
scénario en raison de ce variant c'est à
dire une remise en question des étapes
du déconfinement en france l'expérience
a prouvé que quand en italie au mois de
février c'était l'horreur on a eu la
même chose un mois le pétard tente
variant entre l'aiea a tué deux mille
personnes par jour en angleterre et bien
il est arrivé chez nous deux mois plus
tard donc l'expérience des autres
devrait nous apprendre l'humilité mais
j'ai un peu peur que l'humilité c'est
pas l'activité principalement français
et c'est bien dommage parce que ne rien
faire a aujourd'hui c'est vraiment se
préparer des lendemains qui déchantent
merci beaucoup philippe froguel je
rappelle tout vous êtes généticien et
professeur à l'impérial college de
londres et à l'université lille 2 merci
à vous